DR. NICOLE SAPHIER.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS >> Juan: .
♪ ♪
A GROWING NUMBER OF AMERICANS
THINK THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
TOO LIBERAL AND HE IS GIVING
THEM TRILLIONS OF REASONS TO
THINK THAT.
THE PRESIDENT GETTING READY TO
SUPERCHARGE HIS PROGRESSIVE
AGENDA WITH LEVELS OF SPENDING
WE HAVEN'T SEEN SINCE
WORLD WAR II.
DESPITE SIGNS OF RUNAWAY
INFLATION, HE IS SET TO ROLL OUT
A NEW $6 TRILLION BUDGET PLAN.
IT INCLUDES BIG CHUNKS OF CHANGE
FOR THINGS LIKE INFRASTRUCTURE,
EDUCATION, AND FIGHTING CLIMATE
CHANGE.
BIDEN IS IN OHIO TODAY BOASTING
ABOUT THE ECONOMY AND TAKING
SHOTS ARE REPUBLICANS.
>> THIS IS OUR MOMENT TO REBUILD
AN ECONOMY FROM THE BOTTOM UP
AND THE MIDDLE OUT.
NOT A TRICKLE DOWN ECONOMY EVERY
TIME I TALK ABOUT TAX CUTS FOR
WORKING-CLASS PEOPLE PEOPLE,
IT'S ALL MY GOD, WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO DO?
WELCOME WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
BACK SOME OF THAT 1% MONEY.
EVEN MY REPUBLICAN FRIENDS IN
CONGRESS, NOT A SINGLE ONE OF
THEM VOTED FOR THE RESCUE PLAN
PEERED I'M NOT GOING TO
EMBARRASS ANY OF THEM, BUT I
HAVE HERE A LIST.
[LAUGHTER]
THEY ARE BREAKING ABOUT THE
RESCUE PLAN.
I MEAN, SOME PEOPLE HAVE NO
SHAME.
>> Jesse: AS FOR THE
PRESIDENT'S AGENDA, 46% OF
AMERICANS SAY BIDEN IS TOO
LIBERAL.
THAT'S UP 10% FROM DECEMBER 2019
WHEN HE WAS RUNNING AS A
MODERATE.
AND DANA, I CHECKED THE
INTERNALS, THE PARTISAN
BREAKDOWN IS GOOD.
I APPROVE OF THE POLL THE POLL.
>> Dana: THANK GOODNESS FOR
THAT.
BEFORE YOU CAN TAKE THAT TO THE
BANK.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF BIDEN OUT
THERE GETTING OUT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE, GOING TO OHIO, AND
TRYING TO SELL $6 TRILLION
QUESTION MUST BE TO HE'S GOING
TO HAVE TO DO A LOT OF SELLING
BECAUSE THE LONGER YOU THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILDS WITHOUT A
DEAL, WHILE HE IS PLANNING ON
ADDITIONAL SPENDING, YOU HAVE TO
START ASKING YOURSELF WHAT
PROBLEM ARE YOU TRYING TO SOLVE?
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE COME
FORWARD AND SAID, LOOK, YOU WENT
FROM $2.3 BILLION TO
$1.7 BILLION.
WE ARE WANT TO USE ALL THIS UNST
COVERT MONEY, WHICH MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE TO A LOT OF PEOPLE HERE
WE ALSO HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
POSSIBILITY OF INFLATION.
ED LAWRENCE WAS JUST ON FOX THE
PREVIOUS HOUR TALKING ABOUT HOW
IF YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE A
BARBECUE THIS WEEKEND, THERE'S
ALL THESE PRODUCTS THAT ARE
COSTING A LOT MORE, INCLUDING
MEAT, FOR EXAMPLE.
EVERYBODY IS BUYING THAT.
THE HOUSING MARKET, YOU HAVE
VERY INFLATED PRICES.
AND SO THAT IS BOXING YOUNGER
PEOPLE OUT OF BUYING HOMES.
AND THERE ARE ALL THESE REAL
PROBLEMS.
IT IS OKAY, THE ADMINISTRATION
SHOULD NO, IT'S OKAY TO TAKE THE
AUTOPILOT OFF AND FLY THE PLAIN
YOURSELF WHEN THERE ARE CHANGING
CONDITIONS.
HE'S BRAGGING ABOUT THE ECONOMY,
YET HE WANTS TO SPEND ALL THIS
MONEY TO FIX THE ECONOMY.
WHEN ALL THESE FLASHING YELLOW
LIGHTS ARE LIKE WAIT A MINUTE,
MAYBE WE DON'T NEED THAT.
ON A MODERATE LEVEL, THEY
DEFINITELY HID BEHIND THE
MODERATE CLAIM BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
AS SOON AS HE WAS ELECTED, HE
WAS LIKE WHY ARE YOU SURPRISED?
THIS IS WHAT I SAID I WAS GOING
TO DO DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
BUT REMEMBER, THE CAMPAIGN WAS
WHAT IT WAS.
THEY DIDN'T COVER ANYTHING.
THERE'S NOTHING TO COVER.
SOME PEOPLE SEEM A LITTLE BIT
SURPRISED.
BUT THAT 46% NUMBER, THAT 10%
SINCE JANUARY.
AS COVID CONTINUES TO GET A
LITTLE FURTHER IN THE REARVIEW
MIRROR, I THINK THAT NUMBER
COULD PROBABLY GO HIGHER AND THE
NEXT 100 DAYS.
>> Jesse: I AGREE THAT NUMBER
JUST GOT BLOWN OUT OF THE WATER.
IT'S BECAUSE $6 TRILLION.
THAT'S ALIMONY PAY FOR YOU, BUT
FOR MOST PEOPLE, WHEN THEY LOOK
AT $6 TRILLION, THEY SAY WOW.
>> Geraldo: I'VE NEVER HAD AN
EX-WIFE SAY ANYTHING BAD ABOUT
THAT.
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU THINK
NORMAL AMERICANS ARE LOOKING AT
$6 TRILLION?
DOES NOT REGISTER?
STAY WHEN I DON'T THINK SO.
I REALLY DON'T THINK SO.
I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT BIDEN'S
POPULARITY, HE IS IN THE
MID-50s.
MOST AMERICANS, THE COUNTRY IS
DIVIDED ANYWAY, MOST AMERICANS
WANT THE RICH TO PAY MORE TAXES.
MOST OF OUR KIDS WANT
CORPORATIONS TO PAY MORE TAXES.
HE IS A NICE GUY.
HE CAME HERE TO CLEVELAND TODAY.
YOU KNOW, HE CHEERED EVERYONE
GETTING VACCINATED.
HE CHEERED OUR STATE CONTEST.
A NICE LADY FROM SOUTHEAST OHIO
WON.
A KID GOT A FULL SCHOLARSHIP.
HE TOURED THE TECH SIDE OF IT.
AND BASICALLY INSULTS THE RICH
PLATFORM FOR A DEMOCRAT IN THE
EARLY STAGES OF HIS FIRST TERM.
IT'S NOT A BAD STRATEGY.
I THINK THAT HE IS DOING OKAY.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
$1.91.1 TRILLION?
YOU KNOW, IF IT'S MORE THAN
$100, $1,000, YOU KNOW, THESE
NUMBERS ARE SO ASTRONOMICAL, WE
CAN'T EVEN CONCEIVE OF THEM.
BUT YOU KNOW, IN SUMMARY, I
THINK THAT HE'S DOING OKAY AND
THIS PLAN, YOU KNOW, THE BUILD
BACK BETTER, IF HE CAN STICK TO
HIGHWAYS AND BRIDGES, AND
INTERNET, AND SOME OF THE THINGS
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND AND NOT --
I THINK HE WILL BE FINE.
>> Jesse: YEAH, BUT GREG, TO
GERALDO'S POINT, IF YOU ADD
TRILLIONS AND SPENDING TO THAT,
YOU JACK UP INFLATION AND THE
PEOPLE THAT AREN'T RICH ARE
GOING TO FEEL PINCHED.
>> Greg: YEAH, THAT IS THE
DISINCENTIVE.
THE SAD REALITY IS THAT SMALL
GOVERNMENT ISN'T JUST DEAD.
SMALL GOVERNMENT IS DEAD AND WE
ARE ABUSING THE CORPSES.
I MEAN, THIS IS LIKE, YOU ARE
RIGHT.
NOBODY UNDERSTANDS.
IT IS GROSS.
IT MAKES ME SICK TO MY STOMACH.
LOOK, THE CAMPAIGN STRATEGY THAT
BIDEN HAD IS THE SAME STRATEGY
HAS NOW AS A PRESIDENT.
THE KEY FEATURE IS NO
TRANSPARENCY.
EVERYTHING THE WHITE HOUSE DOES
IS MEANT TO PREVENT YOU FROM
SEEING HOW HARD LEFT THE MISSION
HAS BECOME.
IT'S THE OPPOSITE OF THE
PREVIOUS BOSS, WHETHER YOU LIKE
TRUMP OR YOU HATED HIM, HE DID
EVERYTHING IN FRONT OF YOU.
JOE IS MORE LIKE A PAID
SPOKESMAN FOR AN INFOMERCIAL FOR
A PRODUCT YOU NEVER ACTUALLY
SEE.
AND THEN YOU GET TO THIS POLL,
RIGHT?
IT PROVES THIS AMAZING POINT.
IN POLLS, IT'S LIKE LIBERAL
PERCEPTION.
IT'S PRESENTED AS A NEGATIVE
WHEN YOU ARE SEEN AS TOO
LIBERAL.
EVEN BY THE LIBERALS.
THEY SAY HEY, LOOK AT THIS.
HE'S REALLY LIBERAL.
NO, NO, NO, NO.
THEY CAN'T EVEN AFFORD TO BE
SEEN AS A PURER VERSION OF THEIR
OWN IDEOLOGY, WHICH TELLS YOU TO
COTHINGS.
ONE, LIBERALS CAN ONLY BE
TOLERATED IN SMALL DOSES.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE WHIPPED CREAM
ON ICE CREAM.
AND THE NEED TO LIE ABOUT THEIR
DEATH OF LIBERALISM IN ORDER TO
SURVIVE.
SO JOE BIDEN IS KIND OF LIKE THE
OLD WEST MOVIE.
GERALDO KNOWS WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
WHERE THE BANKS AND HOTELS ARE
SIMPLY ONE-DIMENSIONAL.
BUT BEHIND IT, SOMETHING ELSE IS
GOING ON AND IT'S AOC, IT'S
WOKISM.
IT'S NOT THE TRILLION DOLLAR
STUFF THAT SCARES ME.
IT'S THE WALKISM THAT'S COMING
OUT.
>> Jesse: SPEAKING OF
ICE CREAM, DR. SAPHIER, THE
PRESIDENT GOT A SCOOP OR TWO AND
THE BIG QUESTION WAS WHAT FLAVOR
WAS IT FROM THE MEDIA?
I MEAN, HE COULD JUST COAST ON
STUFF LIKE THAT.
HE NEVER HAS TO REVEAL WHAT GREG
WAS SAYING, WHAT IS GOING ON
BEHIND THE SCENES.
>> Dr. Nicole: I'M GOING TO
BET THAT IT WAS VANILLA.
VERY FLAT VANILLA.
BUT YOU KNOW, COUPLE POINTS I
WANT TO MAKE ON THIS.
FIRST OF ALL, WHEN YOU HAVE
LARRY SUMMERS, THE OBAMA-CLINTON
OFFICIAL WARNING ABOUT SOME OF
THE RISE IN MINIMUM WAGE AND THE
REGULATION AND THE SUPPORT OF
THE UNIONS, SAYING THAT COULD
OBVIOUSLY LEAD TO A VERY LARGE
INFLATION, I LISTEN.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE ALAN
GREENWALD'S SAYING THAT WHAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN RECENTLY DID
WITH THE WAIVER OF INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY RIGHTS CAUSING
BUSINESSES TO QUICKLY RAISE
THEIR PRICES, I'M GOING TO
LISTEN TO THESE PEOPLE.
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
BUT ONE POINT I DID NOTICE FROM
WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS SAYING,
WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT UNITY,
THAT BIPARTISAN UNITY?
HE GOES UP THERE IN LIKE A
CHILD, HE HOLDS UP A LIST OF
REPUBLICAN'S NAMES SAYING THAT
THEY WERE BRAGGING AND TOUTING.
I LOOK SOME OF THOSE UP.
McCARTHY, THE ONE HE SAID HE
WAS BRAGGING ABOUT IT,
McCARTHY JUST POSTED THE
LENGTH FOR SMALL BUSINESSES IN
HIS DISTRICT TO GET FINANCIAL
HELP.
HE SAID I DIDN'T VOTE FOR THIS
BECAUSE I DIDN'T AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING IN IT.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT I
DON'T WANT SUPPORT FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
SO ACTUALLY THINK THAT THIS
CONTINUES, THIS VERBIAGE IS
CONTINUING TO CREATE THE
DIVISION THAT I THINK MOST
PEOPLE VOTED FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T WANT
ANYMORE.
>> Jesse: SO YOU ARE SAYING
THE PRESIDENT MIGHT BE BEING A
LITTLE DISHONEST?
WOW.
I AM SHOCKED TO HEAR THAT.
>> Dr. Nic